Humans are obviously pretty excited about
music.
But what if you're a whale, or a cow, or a
dog?
Do animals like music?
Hello music-lovers, Trace here with the beat
from the street on DNews -- Music is one of
the most basic pleasures humans have.
The oldest surviving musical instruments are
some 40,000 year old bone flutes from southwestern
Germany.
These ancient bone flutes are of such high
quality as to suggest we'd been making instruments
for generations.
Though, we don't really NEED instruments to
make it work, anthropologists have yet to
find a culture that didn't enjoy music, and
according to zoologists it's not just us.
Research out of Boston University and published
in the journal Science, explores the tendency
of birds and whales to follow the same rules
as human music.
Both birds and whales have the ability to
make sounds that AREN'T musical, but they
don't.
They naturally prefer to stay in the realm
of human composition.
Birds have been known to sing in phrases and
rhythms, even adding percussion.
Some use logs to amplify their song, and follow
call and response methods favored by jazz
musicians.
Humpback whale-song uses the A-B-A format
of a musical phrase, followed by a new phrase,
and then a return to an altered form of the
first!
The Beatles are known for A-B-A style, too!
The researchers conclude musical penchance
can't just be a human trait, but that animals
are programmed to enjoy or follow the laws
of harmonics.
A study done in 2001 on English cows found
when cows were played songs while being milked
the speed of the music affected how much milk
they produced!
Specifically, the cows liked slow jams.
Fast songs over 120 beats per minute caused
milk production to drop, but slow songs under
100 beats per minute increased production
by three percent per day!
Unfortunately, cows seem to hate Jamiroquai.
Which makes me like them less.
Neuroscientists and psychologists have studied
the human brain looking for clues to why we
love music so much, and we've talked about
some of the connections in the past on DNews.
Neuroscientists at Harvard Medical School
scanned the brains of people listening to
music and found though the left hemisphere
controls language and the right is considered
the musical half, there was a QUOTE "subtle
interplay," between the two when listening
to music.
More recently, it was discovered jazz musicians
process music not as an aesthetic pleasure,
but as a LANGUAGE.
Using fMRI scans on jazz musicians, they found
our brains derive meaning from musical phrases
-- which sounds to ME a lot like like whales
and birds!
So why do animals like music?
Scientists believe it's built in!
They like it for the same reasons we like
it, it feels right, but more study is needed.
Why do YOU think animals like music?
Comment below and subscribe and you know what...
tweet your favorite songs @DNews Jared will
add them to our Spotify playlist DNews Jamz!
Come listen to music with us.
Thanks for watching!